new york's
metropolitan transportation authority
has been knocked down before
the great depression 911 superstorm
sandy
but its current leader says nothing
matches the current pandemic
by orders of magnitude
in the great depression subway ridership
at the worst was down 13
after the stock market crashed in 1933
was that stat
in the worst days of the pandemic in
march and april subway ridership down 95
percent
right now it's 30 percent of
pre-pandemic levels
we met mta chairman patrick foye inside
the authority's
vast corona maintenance facility 500
cars in this
500 cars 200 employees it's a lot
it's a lot this place is not titled
after the virus
that's always been the name because it's
in corona queens
another bizarre part of 2020 but not as
cruel foy says
as what's happening to millions of
people dependent on public
transportation across the country
new york sits at the top of that food
chain and foye says unless his
organization receives 12 billion dollars
in federal help
over the next several years massive cuts
in jobs and service will take place
why should people from nebraska and iowa
fund
the new york city subway system one
answer to that question
is you mentioned nebraska so let's start
there a company called
kawasaki builds lots of the subway cars
in this barn
kawasaki's equipment subway cars are
built in
japan and in omaha nebraska
we have a production of products in
georgia iowa
florida texas obviously in new york
state
but the mta the our capital plan is 51
billion dollars it's now on pause it
touches literally every state in the
nation including nebraska
in just the new york area one study
estimated 450
000 non-transit jobs are dependent on
public transportation services
foy a first generation american born to
irish immigrants
who grew up just six subway stops from
this building
was appointed by fellow queens native
democratic governor andrew cuomo to lead
the mta
in april 2019.
should people feel safe writing public
transport right now
the answer is absolutely the research
around the world
in the united states and abroad
is that public transit as ridership has
increased has not been a vector of the
virus
to get more people on board the mta is
pioneering new ways to keep people safe
both now and post pandemic that includes
ultraviolet lights
electrostatic sprayers anti-microbial
biostats that create a protective layer
on surfaces
and new kinds of air filters when this
is all over with
yep how do you convince people to get on
public transport again who have not been
on
in months well look new york uh
after the 1918 flu pandemic new york
recovered
the united states experienced the
roaring 20s i think there's going to be
bent up demand offices will open
broadway will come back
the new york mets which are right across
the road are going to have a terrific
season
people are going to want to go see them
some people might disagree with that
last projection i understand
but we do wish you luck absolutely